what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series
um today I'm gonna be reacting to
Matthew Hussey who pays on a first date
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in uh let's get
started Matthew Hussey was he was such a
popular dating coach like five years ago
he's probably still pretty popular but I
don't know too much about his new stuff
but it'll be interesting to see what his
answer is to this who pays on a first
date let's have one more question we had
this person at the back in the stripes
um yeah let's hear from you
during the dating for
him period you know after like four or
five months of dating
um I'm just wondering at what point does
he get
do you have to pay did the woman have to
pay when they go out the guy is asking
did I should there should be half and
half at that point when you're ready at
what point when you're already oh do you
expect women to pay for anything you
don't expect women to pay for any would
you would it be a bonus would it be nice
yeah if she offers to pay that would be
nice
um a lot of the time I'll probably still
pay but sometimes if a woman offers a
pay sometimes I like to see if she's
actually gonna pay well as a girl
offered to pay and then did it
it's weird actually I actually found out
recently that some women go out on date
without even taking their wallets like
on purpose like they don't take any
money they don't take their cards they
just go out so what if you go out and
you meet this guy and then he as well
doesn't have money to pay them both of
you and like a bad situation been dating
for
right
look okay uh to give you a quick answer
on first but I wanna I wanna go away I
wanna go back and see this woman what
does she bring to the table is she
overweight I can't see
she kind of looks chunky I've been
dating for four or five months right
yeah
well then the question is how often are
you like cooking for it like what are
you doing what do you look okay uh to
give you a quick answer on firstly I
think we should just deal with the who
should pay thing to begin with who when
you're on a date who should pay
I know I mean that's what I told them
you know I'm sorry
I'm dating we're dating but here's
okay
he's supposed to pay yeah but you're
supposed to have sex with him whenever
he says no
[Laughter]
whenever well you're supposed to be a
virgin if we're gonna this is the
problem okay now men do and will pay and
like I'm not even arguing that men
shouldn't pay on the first date because
we live in reality you know it's just
not gonna go well if men try to go 50
50. the women are just gonna go to the
next guy that won't do that you know I'm
just I'm just being honest okay I'm not
gonna I will not lie to you guys but but
but the whole point is the entitlement
that's the whole point it's like you
know she's saying after four or five
months he asks that I pick up the bills
sometimes you know I think that's a
pretty reasonable when it's been four or
five months you know I I don't think
that's crazy but there's a caveat to
that though
back in the day I used to believe yeah
you have to pay every time but now if I
go on a date
and the date doesn't go well I'm
probably gonna ask to split the check
man
well yeah no you know it's crazy as a
chick if if I if I think the date didn't
go well I don't want to see him again
I'll ask to split it just because I
don't I don't like I don't want him to
think I don't want him to think it went
well do you know what I mean like
because you don't have to think it will
well mine is because I don't want to
have to tell her that I don't want to
see her again so I know if I split the
check with her she's probably not going
to want to see me again oh I do it
because I don't want him to like
expect anything I don't know I don't
know I just I'm like ah we'll just
sit but
I don't know what I thought about was
it's like if we're gonna ask for
traditional outcomes we gotta first make
sure we're traditional women because
traditional women don't have a problem
getting traditional outcomes you do not
see like the most feminine the most
traditional women get the most
traditional outcome so you kind of got
to ask yourself if I'm not getting a
traditional outcome maybe I need to work
on something but another way to know the
real traditional woman for instance I've
never seen a woman who goes on a date
and then who claims she's traditional
and then maybe if the guy doesn't pull
out the chair
most women will pull it out themselves
yeah yeah a real traditional woman is
going to stand there and look at him
that's the reality yeah that's so true
where does this double standard come
from
I'm sorry it's the reality you guys can
you can you can moan at it or you want
but the moment you say to a guy you have
to [__] pay for my time
you're saying this relationship isn't
equal
this relationship isn't equal my time is
worth more than yours so you should pay
for it
I wonder what Paradigm that sets up
here's my view if you go on a date with
a guy
and you don't offer to pay your share
you weren't taught right
if you go on a date if you go on a date
with a guy and you don't offer to pay
your share you weren't taught right you
think that's true
yeah I think it's true too I just think
it's like polite but most guys aren't
even gonna accept it yeah but but you
still have to offer because the thing is
if you don't offer then it's kind of
like entitlement yeah so most guys when
you offer to be like ah no don't worry
about it but I think a lot of women are
scared to offer because they think maybe
the guy might say okay then pee
but then if that happens then that's
your way out as well so I don't know why
people are scared of all these
hypotheticals yeah and he doesn't pay he
wasn't taught right
I can tell you right now if I was dating
someone and they never offered to pay I
wouldn't be dating them
I can tell you that now if they never
offered to pay I would not be dating
them because I'd say this is the most
polite they're ever going to be
and they're not even trying to pay now
um
what does that say about my future but I
I look
this let me comment this from a
different angle
I would
I would be treating I will always treat
my partner how I would treat my best is
a bit feminist he's a bit I can hear it
because you can hear it in the language
as they don't realize it's like you can
hear feminism in people's language they
don't realize it's feminism but it's
just so much in the media and like in
the
um messaging and even in our schools and
even in like our parents relationship
how he's saying I would treat my partner
like my best friend that's that's
insinuating that you guys are equals
you're not equals I would be treating I
will always treat my partner how I would
treat my best friend
and I wouldn't apply a different
standard to my partner than my best
friend I wouldn't go I wouldn't say I I
do not like I just think when you treat
your husband like your best friend it's
like it just implies you have equal say
when it's a more tradition if you want
to be in it which I don't know but
people think I have an issue with 50 50
relationships I don't have an issue with
them I just don't think they work like I
think if you look at the outcomes and
the data they don't work but more
traditional relationships like you don't
see the women referring to her husband
as her best friend like your husband is
a role and let's always go out her
husband wife it's a role Aaron and you
always pay
I'd say let's be teammates here in
whatever way we can yeah see that's
feminism 50 50. maybe by the way
proportionately what you can do is less
than what he can do that's a different
thing
if he says to you and even when you're
married you're supposed to have one bank
account anyway I mean like we're not we
we live in such a post-marriage society
people don't think about that but I mean
I heard this one chick talking about her
divorce and she was like oh I paid all
the bills like I just I put like I drain
my bank account paying for things and I
was just thinking like you're not
supposed to have separate bank accounts
it's supposed to be one and this is the
crazy thing women will trust their body
with a guy like they'll trust a man with
their body but they won't trust a man
with their money they'll trust a man to
be the father of their kids but they
won't trust a man to make financial
decisions it's just it's like it's more
the mindset I'm talking about so if you
said you're meant to have one bank
account do you mean like they can only
have one bank account and can't have
separate accounts outside of that or
can they have like separate like their
own personal well I mean they could they
could do what they want but I think for
the woman you should have one bank
account yeah like I think they both it
should just be a joint bank account that
the husband's in charge of that's more
traditional
more 50 50 as separate bank accounts I
think
I think age I understand why men keep it
separate but like a traditional
relationship if the woman's working she
hands her paycheck to the guy and he
decides what to do with it you disagree
yeah I mean I know that's what the
traditional relationship is but I don't
think that's ever going to work you know
more than times yeah I mean that's the
problem is the way the laws are today I
mean if I was a dude I'd just put all my
[__] in Bitcoin
I want to go stay at the top hotel in
Big Sur this weekend and it's 1500 bucks
a night and you say I can't I don't have
the money it's his job to say it doesn't
matter I didn't do it so you could pay I
did it because I want to go and I want
to take you great
that's what that is right
or if you both agree to go on holiday
and you have a fifth of his earning
potential you say I want to contribute
to a fifth of this holiday it's overly
simplistic but you get what I'm saying
right I'll contribute on the level I can
contribute let me tell you what means
something to a guy trying
that means something to a guy when he
feels that you're not even trying to
contribute that's when he feels used
because any guy who's really confident
and self-respecting if the woman never
is even trying to contribute
he feels like uh he's being taken
advantage of and it has nothing to do
with money
it has to do with the lack of gesture
so I would be looking at if you like
this guy maybe if you're in different
positions figure out what you want to
contribute proportionately or what you
can contribute proportionately and treat
him as you would your best friend
yeah I don't really like the treat a guy
is your best friend that's not mine I
just don't think that because men and
women that we treat our friends
differently like I don't want to talk to
my husband the way I would talk to a
friend and I and I really would not want
a guy to talk to me in the same way he
talks to his friends have you guys ever
been in dude's locker room I have not
but but I worked in a plumbing tech
company and it may as well have just
been like a dude's locker room when we
would go to these like plumbing places
like the places where they train
plumbers and like the HVAC that sort of
thing I'm telling you guys are like so
rude to each other I'm like I could not
I could not but but and that's that's
the thing I I really think feminism
wants us to be the same and saying that
we're best friends we can just be best
friends it's like implying that we're
the same but I did like that he was
showing how
um women
will ask for traditional outcomes but we
don't always want to put you know our
end of the bargain in but let me know
what you guys think you know in the
comments um like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time